catherine cassidy est ce qu'on pourrait
appeler une experte du couponing en dix
ans elle est passée maître dans l'art
d'accumuler les bons rabais une
stratégie qui lui a permis d'économiser
des dizaines de milliers de dollars
depuis un an elle partage ses conseils
sur les réseaux sociaux où elle est
suivie par près de quatre cent mille
personnes
il est évident que la pandémie et
l'inflation ont fait mal au portefeuille
des gens et le couponing est une des
choses qui leur permet de reprendre le
contrôle sur leurs finances personnelles
dit elle
jessica moore elle fait plutôt partie de
ces jeunes milena rios passionnés de
finances depuis dix ans elle aide les
jeunes adultes à atteindre leurs
objectifs financiers à travers les
réseaux sociaux elle dit qu en deux ans
le nombre d'influenceurs en finance a
explosé sur tik tok par exemple le mot
clé ce toc toc a été utilisé plus de
deux milliards et demi de fois pour
trouver du contenu sur la bourse de hong
kong cette information est plus
accessible que jamais ce qui est génial
dit elle en ajoutant qu en revanche
n'importe qui peut donner des conseils
sur les réseaux sociaux sans avoir les
compétences requises
les créateurs de contenu aussi doit
faire de l'argent il accepte donc
parfois de faire la promotion de
produits qui ne conviennent pas aux
besoins de leurs audiences ajoute cet
autre influenceurs en finances
personnelles de toronto c'est pourquoi
la commission des valeurs mobilières de
la colombie britannique a récemment
proposé de nouvelles règles si elles
sont adoptées elle forcerait entre
autres les personnes qui font la
promotion de titres boursiers spécifique
à divulguer s'ils reçoivent une
compensation financière pour le faire et
si elles détiennent des actions ou des
produits financiers dérivés de
l'entreprise ou du fonds
d'investissement concernés les
contrevenants pourraient s'exposer à des
amendes allant jusqu'à un million de
dollars l'autorité des marchés
financiers saluent l'initiative mais
souligne qu'il est difficile de
réglementer ce genre d'activités en
ligne le danger serait de m la pas
beaucoup trop et de croire que tous les
influenceurs qu'on trouve sur les
mesures socio un jour pourront se
plieront ou un respecteront une
quelconque réglementation l' agence
provinciale considère que la
sensibilisation et la prudence demeure
les meilleurs outils de prévention en ce
moment et sans rien nous lie en rade au
canada toronto